you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game between Bhaskaran audubon
playing on the white end and magnus
carlsen this was from round 2 of the
2018 Tata Steel chess tournament masters
section we have an e4 e5 game for
night's game with d4 this is noted as
the Scotch variation first dozen moves
of this game are neither players taken
are neither players surprised all pretty
standard stuff some pressure now on e4
now that the knight is pinned so Knights
are exchanged black takes towards the
center I should t3 d5e takes d5 Carlsen
castles straight away you could just
capture on t5 as well black with the
last move is giving white an opportunity
maybe be greedy this would not be a wise
choice because what are you gonna do
with your king after Bishop g4 to e8
ideas where's his safe haven it's
unclear white doesn't bite
simply castles and only now C takes d5
Bishop g5 he's no longer a good defender
of d5 and
Bishop's ready to take out the night and
basically the Queen from defending d5 so
c6 is there d5 is now secure Queen f3
the bishop did his job on b4 so he's
relocating initially this main strike
some is a bit awkward to deploy the
bishop on d6 instead of let's say e 7
where you know you're you're breaking
the pin but black at this stage is
content with having the King side
structure damaged with this Bishop takes
Knight idea and that's what we're going
to have in the game
the imbalance will be related to the
pawn structure and the mine minor pieces
so Rick a 2e1 rook b8 p3 and a five I
described 885 is basically placing a
constraint on the c3 Knight if he goes
somewhere other than a four this pawn
goes further and both the a pawn and the
rook converge on b3 and the pawns ready
to exchange himself off the isolated
pawn is ready to exchange himself off
for a perfectly healthy white pawn on b3
so some squares now provided for the
white king similar for team black Bishop
takes Knight Queen takes and well here
we go this is the main feature of this
game well this doesn't actually last for
too long but the structure throughout
from this point from this point on this
structure is the biggest feature in this
in this game eventually we're going to
have a knight for dark square Bishop
exchange but the structure is the key
feature here
Knight to e2 is follow-up there are some
gaps over here now that the structure is
weakened and the knight is ready to I up
two of them
and while he was also eyeing up d4 so
that's taken out with c5 Knight g3 so
what to do
to prepare to deal with the night on f5
rook te and after Knight f5 Bishop Fe if
the knight goes to h5 this is easily
defended with Bishop to e5
the bishop would be controlling the
night and on a really good square from
a5 and there's even d4 and c3 as a good
squares for the bishop so Knight f5
Bishop f8 and the knight immediately
jumps right in and he has to be captured
so otherwise there's a fork so there we
go
Bishop takes Knight rook takes Bishop e6
move 21 we are only 15 moves away and
this game is over that to me is is
surprising this is the key position that
I really want to touch on in this game
and by viewing this game I feel that I
grew some as a player what are the key
features I already pointed out the pawn
structure as being the key feature what
about the pawn structure is so important
well
the queenside ponds are most important
here the kingside ponds not so much even
though black has isolated ponds the
fractured kingside structure this isn't
where the attention is going to be for
the rest of the game it's on the Queen
side on the Queen side is where we're
going to eventually see each side with a
passed pawn
moreover the bishop positions are very
important you'll notice that as black
pushes on the Queen side
this gains some steam this this hits
with tempo
the black bishop doesn't have that issue
ok c4 is going to hit with a punch and
this is a race position so every tempo
counts
so from here what we have is rip to d1
this isn't one of the top suggestions by
the computer computers a fan of playing
Rick to a sovereign the rook on d6 Erik
Samira Khan eise evan is I don't want to
say out of play
but definitely
well under control it's almost like the
bishop you know the bishop kind of cuts
off the rook he's not able to connect
with any other white piece you know
there's no let's say convergence on f7
this is well supported so he's on e7 he
go to a7 but he's you know that's it
this is one of the suggestions to go to
a7 this would force rook to e8 otherwise
a5 is going to fall so white has the
option to play rook a7 in play this
position with one less major piece on
board and the other is to play f4 what's
the idea behind that four well to rattle
the bishop post on e6 maybe even you
know after f4 and f5 there might even be
some ID with g4 and after a capture f5
challenging the strong bishop post on e6
okay well in the game its rook to d1 c4
he can't be captured capturing and c4
here that's basically game over
the choices are Bishop e2 or Bishop f1
at this stage
what's wrong with capturing well you're
going to end up in a pin and this isn't
going to be any fun rook b1 eventually
one key move first King f8 and only then
rook to be one rook b1 straightaway
allows a check and then defense one
little move King f8 and only then rook
there and that's the ball game so I
can't take Bishop e2 in the game a4
black really wants this beep on to make
a capture why well one of the ideas is
to not only get to the second-ranked but
to do so and strike it two ponds that
are unprotected this is like some golden
square 14 black get your rook to be -
it's hitting everything
hitting the weak points in White's camp
B takes a four in the game now I was
pointing out get to the B 2 square you
can't do that for tactical reasons can't
just jump right in here at B 2 at this
stage and your rooks unprotected that
would allow Bishop takes c4 so instead
we have Bishop f5 hunting down c2 are
trying to hunt down the c2 point this is
where white now goes astray some
miscalculation whitehat at this stage
the best move is to get the pawn out of
harm's way with c3 but in the game
Bishop f3 so some miscalculation I
imagine by Audubon it's easy to go wrong
in this position this is a race position
plenty of you have to calculate deeply
here we currently have a past a pond and
a two-to-one majority here just
considering the C and D files one of
these guys is going to be passed soon
enough
so one of the ideas with Bishop f3 is on
a capture on c2 the rook can now
recapture on d5 we have an exchange of
pawns Carlson presses with d4 and this
opens the bishops eyes he now observes
that promotion Square
so now the bond the the pawn takes off
85 Bishop takes c2 black as it turns out
is simply going to be faster in this
pawn race we know how valuable two pawns
on the six can be they're more valuable
than a rook and well black is just
winning this race from here on out every
move by team black is a top move Roxy
won the rooks are exchanged the bishop
is out of the pawns way
Brooksie seven what else is white white
to try here
going forward with this pawn race don't
we just highlight this variation a six
if a six we would have C 3 a 7 C 2 let's
say white takes a timeout to stop the
promotion the Fonz just continued to
march white would promote first but who
cares how you dealing with two pawns on
your second rank it's game over for Team
white black is simply too fast
in the game it's rook c7 c3
for the moment c2 is prevented rook e8
c5 black is now up upon this guy's going
nowhere and the plan here is exchange
rooks and push these guys bishop c2 for
the moment
stopping d3 Bishop e6 King f1 and rook
c8 another rook is gone you can't avoid
the rook exchange here with rook here
that would be silly Bishop c4 and d3
follows so there's just nothing here the
rooks are exchanged a6 is controlled in
the game it's king to eat do and king to
e2 doing something else like Bishop d3
Carlsen could play there's only one
winning move here Carlsen could play
Bishop a6 and that's game over Bishop
takes Bishop c2
can't stop the pond from promoting
so just a few more moves played out in
this one kingi to Bishop a6
if the bishop blocks c2 in the game its
king f3 and after d3 audubon has had
enough
game over white resigns
I don't know how to describe this one
it's another case of I'm not making it
look too easy in a way this position
where we have well I was pointing out
the key features being the queenside
structure right here after the exchange
of nights or the bishop for night
exchange this position right here the
key feature Queen side pawn structure
and the location of the bishops in how
the move c4 is hitting with tempo this
is a time sensitive position and
if you're in a race position and you
know you're getting hit by your
opponent's moves well you're getting hit
by an opponent's move like c4 throwing a
punch of your bishop and you're having
to react retreat this factors in and
that's what contributed to this loss on
the on the white and very easy to go
wrong in these race positions so if we
have a look at the tale the tape of this
one if you're curious about the average
sent upon loss for each player here's
the graph pretty even throughout all the
way into endgame land a little shift
there with Bishop to have five this was
a moment believe that was the moment
there where c3 could have been played
but after Bishop f3 a big shift at that
stage and then just just a growing
advantage for team black from that point
on in that race position final tally
here Audubon
Suren accuracies for mistakes one
blunder 40 average sent upon lasse
karlsson two inaccuracies zero mistakes
zero blunders with a 12 average sent
upon loss the lower the number the
better so as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you're
having a great day and I'll catch you in
the next one that's all for now take
care bye
you